you know those videos where people are
just insanely lucky and it just looks
like the universe falls into place for
them
that's not what we're looking at today
we're looking at people
unlucky very bad luck so i can feel less
bad about
everything that's [ __ ] i'm actually
excited for this
what the hell am i looking at
oh no oh no
oh he's so sad no
ow ow it hurts
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you already
down about [ __ ]
this oh i don't feel good at all i was
supposed to feel good about people's
pain not
animals
okay moving on quick some yeah an old
lady hurt okay
i'm kidding it's 80 dollars you have
until september 16th
to take care of this uh get you to sign
there with access
so you don't even give a warning for
this you've been driving around for six
months like that i'm truthful
well i'm not gonna give you a warning
for something you've been driving for
six months
yes
[Applause]
well then you better fix it you had six
months because you're under arrest
step out
step out step out i'm giving you a law
for or step out
she locks herself in ah woman now
oh no oh woman
jesus christ oh you're back
that's not unlucky this is stupid the
thing is okay i get the police are crazy
in america right
this will never happen anywhere else but
people wouldn't just take off
either in europe i can't imagine this
happening my house burned
but at least i got a lot of likes on
reddit so i mean it's okay
my friend was works as an extra in
movies in this stock photography
just saw him picture that sex of the
person
in florida oh [ __ ]
he's wearing his suit he looks nice
they're like
sex offender that's it we got him my dad
says google is doing this stupid thing
where the blur the top left part of the
result
facebook is doing it too actually i
think i'm on to then
oh that's wonderful mark zuckerberg is
in my computer he's blurring my screen
i can't believe these in-laws invited us
over for dinner
it was a trap here assemble the table so
you can eat
i would love this i love assembling
furniture which has nothing to do
with me being swedish stop being racism
[Laughter]
price carrot i've been resisting pulling
up
man that's a big boy right there
oh that's great women slip
on ice let's just rush to help her
they're gonna fall yeah
idiots
oh my god dude you could tell a look on
it
what a [ __ ] douchebag this is almost
television oh my
i think it's a psychological thing i
think they have to deal with these
packages so much that they
take out their anger and frustration on
the package like there's no reason to be
this
extra weight they're like they're
clearly doing anything
on purpose right oh my gosh dude i
literally lost my wallet the other day
the exact same way
your own fault dude get out of here
always check your
chair where you [ __ ] let me guess it's
gonna spike
and up he goes yeah
[Laughter]
why am i laughing it's really sad but
still it's jesus christ
well then i'm sure the system can handle
it i don't see a problem here
summer's in england everyone it's great
everyone loves it
everybody friends keep for hours to see
how it works express
oh wow that was so cool
[Laughter]
i love that one yes should we tell them
oh god what is that demon there's a day
man
holy [ __ ]
ah what do you do
hey bro a demon just crawling to your
car
pull over i whipped myself
into frustrated race trying to find my
drill for half an hour
oh man i seriously when i built my
closet i thought for sure
on the charger there needs to be a
button to find your drill because you
always put it somewhere
and you always forget where the [ __ ] you
put it this yeah i can relate to this
trying to paddle sir but this dolphin
mafia
oh that was great love dolphins they're
total [ __ ]
god bless you dolphins man gets tattoo
he found on his pup not knowing it means
he's neutered
we are linked we are the same now
i also cut my balls oh my god i called
it in that last video they're wrong by
running over your pet's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh my god dude thanks ramba for keeping
my house clean
oh that's so good
my new favorite gift i did not expect
that
oh that's great
he immediately starts going at the other
one uh
bruh stop all right let me just do that
again don't worry lay still
now that's what i'm talking about that's
what i want
yeah pain
oh whoa whoa
that's the lucky they were wearing the
harness jesus christ
sheesh we gotta drive next to each other
for no reason god damn it what the [ __ ]
you know this is america i know me
that's so annoying
[Laughter]
it's a time traveling microwave steins
gate microwave look at it
nice
that's a damn good question
oh yes i mean no that's awful
no no no
no
two thousand pounds
the worst part is not having your left
oh my god it all play now
ah oh my seat doesn't seem to recline
better do it more oh
geez nice well done
you did it here he comes
mr plow hell yeah
love it
[Laughter]
yes
it looks so cool oh no
[Laughter]
yes i love it 10 out of 10.
brings me joy took some some aspirin
when i was tired it was really late and
i realized an hour later
that what i took was not aspirin
vegetable laxative oh
god i didn't know there was aspirin that
makes you sleepy too
i did that during a shoot of scare
pewdiepie and it freaked me the [ __ ] out
like oh i have a headache gotta put
something before this long shoot we have
no you sleep now
well we know who the stronger brother is
now
mmm yummy potatoes so good
how many calories in that bro
yes yes yes
get the second class
he keeps going they keep
oh that was beautiful i feel great now
don't you feel good
you look good my hair give me ever
subscribe
subscribe check out cheap fuel it's
really tasty it's so tasty i finish it
hey the good beauty bad bye